hi everyone thank you for joining us
today and a very warm welcome to the
third episode of studio sml sessions
brave new world this event is presented
by the press room and supported by the
design singapore council and the
national design center i'm felicia from
the design singapore council and i will
be your mc for today
today's studio sml session brave new
world will ponder the importance of our
roots to make creative breakthroughs and
find new frontiers we sometimes have to
go back to the beginning but what does
this mean for design you'll hear more
from our panel of speakers through a
presentation of their works and
perspectives in the first half of the
session before we move into a panel
discussion and q a segment in the later
half so first of all we have tani chung
creative director of produce a multiple
award-winning design studio with
prototyping capabilities produce was set
up to deliver highly robust and bespoke
design solutions from concept to
construction
and joining us today is also jonathan
yuen founder of roots an independent
branding and creative design studio with
a keen focus on cultures ideas and craft
roots has developed award-winning
meaningful design stories for many
notable brands businesses and
institutions
and last but definitely not the least we
have voon wong director of viewport
studio joining us from the uk
viewport studio is an architecture and
design studio that is based in both
london and singapore they have designed
a series of award-winning spaces and
products that combines innovation with
the rigorous attention to detail
moderating our session for today is
kelly ching founder of studio sml and
the founder and creative director of the
press room a publishing and design
consultancy so without further ado i'll
hand the time over now to kelly to
officially kick start today's session
kelly over to you please thank you
felicia
hi everyone thank you for joining us at
this talk today
and you won't be disappointed because we
have three really good designers today
um and i'm a big fan of all their works
as well so i think they are all going to
be very inspired
without much further ado uh i would want
to do a short intro of uh each one uh
just to add on to felicia uh punditchen
is a strong advocate for parametric
architecture still not so common in
singapore but uh asian has devoted much
of his practice in pursuit of
redefining what craftsmanship means in
this digital mirror through
through this parametric architecture so
uh here i'm going to hand over to annie
chen
all right thank you very much for the
introduction
i'll just share my screen now i i
actually run uh three companies so i
have type zero architecture produced and
server structure
so these three companies has slightly
different focuses as well as expertise
but
they are put together over a course of
eight years um
you know i was in practice since 2013
and
the the primary motivation behind this
assembly was actually making
so right at the beginning i wanted to
[Music]
make design and make so
having
a really nice workshop to
experiment in was something that i
wanted to do for my studio
to model after a school environment
where we could simply just go downstairs
and
test out our ideas in the workshop
so in 2013 uh produce occupied a half
a workshop area and with our design
studio on the second floor
we got hold of a cnc machine and
a laser cutter and then i began our
journey for design and make
gradually
we managed to grow and in 2017
we decided to
make the workshop a separate entity and
i collaborated and partnered with emily
from
analog to start superstructure and
superstructure
concentrates on doing digital
fabrication
and unique installations
um we are into uh
i think the third year of our operations
and we are getting hold of
a 3d printer
a large one as well as looking forward
to have our first robot
this year
so the type of projects we do
collectively between these three
companies range from furniture to
in the middle is a music theater
a private for a private home as well as
experimental structures
and right now we are actually also
working on mass engineer timber
buildings
so
i've titled my talk as project synthesis
because
throughout this eight years i
find that
the experiences that we had allow us to
put together not just these three
different companies
but
i see that we can accumulate accumulate
uh knowledge to go forward into the
fourth industrial revolution
so about a hundred years ago
le corbusier started with this
this simple
building
and he wanted to mass produce this
to
satisfy the growing demand for housing
at a time where the frame was uh
pre-fabricated
and everything filling in is customized
by the
inhabitants so he was very much ahead of
his time
um but that herald in uh entire century
of
rc frame and steel frame buildings which
very much typify
what modernist buildings is about
and to a large extent technological uh
production
became its own kind of process that
also conversely limits the architectural
expression
but
can we continue to build using
this
technique
because actually concrete is one of the
most destructive material
that we have it contributes to
a huge amount of carbon emission
and embodied carbon
is currently
10 of global emission annually and
rising
likewise it depletes uh like st uh like
concrete steel uh steel production
depletes the earth and emits a lot of
uh carbon
and uh it also is very labor intensive
and all these problems are kind of
exemplified and amplified during the
pandemic
and
last but not least it is not recyclable
so most of them become
placed into landfills
so
we have had um almost 100 years of
access and waste in this predominant
way of building and right now uh the
digitalization process that we have
in
the construction industry would allow us
to combine all these different
strategies um
from robotics to ai
to data
analytics and to we can combine all
these strategies to
[Music]
create a new digital
platform and also method
that would herald in the next
you know
development of architecture in the
future
so i see this as a possibility for the
architect to
once again control the entire means of
production of architecture and to kind
of influence this production
we are at this stage where we no longer
is subservient to the building
technology that is out there really we
can at this moment design new
machines
specific to the
system of building that we want to
create
so this computer computational workflow
[Music]
is important for this entire
transformation and it's a case where we
need to
jump back and forth and do multiple
iterations
and uh digitalization uh and computation
allow us to do that
um we have actually uh
despite having these three separate
companies uh we have a department that
spends across these three companies and
this is the computational team it is
also a department where we
accumulate our knowledge and to look
forward to new building systems
so i'll just show a number of projects
that we have done over the course of
eight years
primarily the first set of
experiments was to look at how flat
materials can become
you know an organic
surface or doubly curved surface
so the first project was herman miller
and extra shop in shop at park mall and
here we
combined the um
you know used uh inspiration from eems
furniture where it's it is made
primarily of molded plywood and we look
at a geometry
and building technique that would be
able to put together flat pieces of
plywood without steam bending or molding
i created a triangle
triangulated
[Music]
grid system where the panels are simply
hooked
to each other
and this is combined with other
components that would then form the
entire system
so
this is almost like redesigning a brick
although this brick has to be put
together
in sequence and each brick has a
specific position within the entire
geometry
um the entire structure is built of four
thousand over pieces of plywood
uh modules each piece is about three
millimeters thick
and it forms a rigid grid shell
that became a skin for hermann miller
shop within extra
so
we learned a lot from this project
and at that time we did not have our cnc
machine but soon after this project we
realized very quickly that in order to
have
experimentations of our own
we needed a machine
to be able to have this rapid iteration
of
options
so the second
shop in shop
was
also by extra and they had to move out
of park mall and into
marina square so here we wanted to
reduce the number of parts and by doing
that we looked at how we can maximize
the basic
size of plywood which is four by eight
feet
and we exported a tailoring onto plywood
so this is an initial test of cutting
dots into the plywood and then stitching
it back up to allow the plywood to be
bent
without
naturally and without any steam bending
process
we had to digitize this digitalize it in
order to build it at a larger scale so
here we are using a physics engine to
simulate
the
elasticity
the bending of the plywood
and we had to do multiple iterations
this is where the digital fabrication
process and prototyping comes in very
handy because then from this experiments
we created the dna or rather the
kind of relationship between the dart
angle and the surface deformation
angle
and this became a parameter for the
overall system
so
we had a proof of concept with a
one-to-one mock-up
and then uh looking at how we can best
uh exemplify this new system uh we look
at creating the minimal surface just
like how freyjoto
described the minimal surface with a
soap film
bubble
we tested it
as a
with with this
technique onto
just simple wires
and once again we had to use a physics
engine
to simulate the
minimal surface onto the frame
that became the 400 components that we
have
and this time round the plywood was made
of two millimeters thick plywood and
the the entire fabrication and assembly
process was actually very simple
uh we only had fresh graduates
from all different disciplines some of
them are accountant trained to just
basically stitch the plywood together
using cable tie and they are put
together using pop rivets and the way it
is being assembled uh are very much like
how you would pull up a canvas
and finally the the outcome
um i find that it is very fit
uh
for its technique uh these holes that
you see here are meant to relax the the
surface at
the specific points so that they do not
crack and it became a kind of signature
expression of this entire system
and and
basically everyone
could form their own
[Music]
experience an impression of this uh
structure some of them think of it as
caves and some of them
uh think of it like a bazaar
with this uh very casual fabric uh
pulled over
but um i i think the main
important point is that they learn a lot
more about uh herman miller and the
early eems furniture through this
process of experimentation
um
furthermore
we
tried the same
to look at how flat materials can become
organic surface using
another format which is to look at
ribbon
and here it's a collaboration with for
mica and we use
the laminate for my car laminate to
reinforce plywood
again it's three millimeters thick but
because it is cut in strip it allows for
a torsion
to a certain degree and here we
created almost like a basket structure
um that is um calculated using a
gravitational model
and
at the end of the project uh two weeks
long exhibition i load tested it myself
and
[Music]
it is interesting that to build this 10
meters wide structure and 5 meters tall
structure we only utilize one pallet of
material when we finally demolished it
so
this research though
processes can drastically reduce the
amount of material we use
as we design
so the next set of experimentation is to
look at how we can reduce complex
surfaces into simple panels flat panels
so that it's easier for fabrication and
so here we look at measuring masonry
vaults and
vault structure and this iteration uh
this was for an office
and uh this is like a
scroll that is going through the office
creating
um
different uh
spaces for different uh departments
within the office so it becomes an
office that's open plan yet uh there are
uh kind of
spaces for or
different cells within
within this office
as a triangulated panel structure we
wanted to use something that is
developed finger joint in this case they
are
compressed together using bolt and nut
so
and they align the the different panels
together so it's actually very easy to
put together
and uh the entire process was cut using
our five axis cnc machine
and and then they are pre pre-assembled
in strips
and um
the assembly process simply is to put
the strips together
uh by bolting
um so because the edges are all
calculated specific to how the overall
topology will perform
they simply uh fall into shape to form
the arch
and the other good thing is that we can
pre-plan a lot of uh circuses uh in here
on the right you see lights being
already uh planned within the structure
and we also
kind of dovetail the
sprinkler insulation
as we produce
the panels
finally
it is a structure that is
sound absorbent we clad the underneath
with acoustic felt and
other side with
raw length it is almost paper thin it's
overall 40 millimeters thick
and
kind of more than 50 meters long
and following that we started to look at
hexagonal grids
system to form a vault and this was for
a
entertainment space within a private
home
right now we are into the
third or fourth iterations uh of this
system
and uh
we are able to uh kind of already supply
them as a building system and product
for any space so even the the the space
we can easily recreate a rich shell
a vault using
our
script and
they will break them down into its
component parts which we will then also
have the
milling
information
a ready input
and ready for production
so likewise we always
do the dry installation
and this is used to
communicate to the installers
and the the the builder how this whole
system works so this beats any drawings
you know
and they communicate best in terms of
translating
drawing
to form
that is a demonstration
so here we have all the cells
before they are finished
so they are filled with rockwool
and then uh during the
rendering we have
and the final build so
with the digital process we are already
looking at a digital tween before
anything goes on site
going up the scale in this panelization
idea we receive a call from
a you know a music hall project in the
middle east and they are using um
acoustic panel fabricator from ireland
engaged by this irish company
to calculate and break the this organic
surface into component parts so here we
used uh
our geometrical analysis
to then look at what is the most
efficient way to lay them out so that we
have minimal milling so these circles
that you see here are the
minimum milling that we need to do to to
make the curved surface and we even
calculated how the vineyard will be laid
onto this doubly curved surfaces
and finally
this is
the process during installation
and
we start to see that our products are no
longer a physical installation but more
and more it is a digital file that can
be
exported to any part of the world and if
they share the same machine
that we have we actually then speak the
same language in terms of fabrication
one of our main
ambition here is to drive the whole uh
transformation into mass engineer timber
buildings and so in 2019 we started
experimenting with reconstituted timber
with a company called one wood and here
we started looking at
pre-fabricated standard panels that can
then replace rc concrete panels
so on the left there is a one-way slab
and on the right it is the two-way slab
we wanted to reduce the amount of
material used here and at the same time
using fast-growing
plantation timber that we can find in
the region
we can then
further
our research to look at
mass customized bespoke
structures where the column positions
can can freely uh be moved during the
design process and
the warfares will reorganize accordingly
so in 2019 we did this uh
simple uh experiment at art expo at
marina bay sands
and we
recently just completed our proof of
concept with
design singapore good
design research grant
and right now we are looking forward to
further this experimentation
fibers of timber that can be either
recycled or from very very fast growing
plantation timber
the harvest time is uh less than seven
years
and
they can then be pressed together with
all these cavities to reduce weight but
also
to
put in services like lighting
and water pipes
so we are currently conducting a series
of tests to look at how
it performs structurally
and then we will in time get the
certification
that is compatible compatible with the
eu code
so just to conclude i think with the
fourth industrial revolution we have a
few
change in terms of how
a mindset change we need to concept of
construction
changing to
fabrication in which
things are built offline within
controlled environment where waste is
drastically reduced and pollution
drastically reduced it is more efficient
and safe
and then we need to start looking at
building as a product where all its
component parts are fitted together just
like in the automobile industry this is
important to
[Music]
create a
better efficiency and productivity in
the in the entire building industry
and finally we need to propose as much
as possible these new technologies
whenever there's an opportunity
so
throughout
this few years we have been proposing
for example concrete printing
technologies together with met
structures
in some of our competitions
and finally uh um hopefully by then we
can uh kind of really ask this question
like how luis louis can
ask the brick what does the brick want
to be in this case well
what will building system become and
what is the greatest potential that we
can use from a new building system
created thank you very much
thank you icho let us now welcome
jonathan yuan founder of roots to join
us on screen please hello hi
uh everyone uh thanks for your time um
i'm jonathan so i'm a graphic designer
and i run a independent design studio
called roots specializing in creative
directions branding and graphic design
so basically what i do or what we do is
that we consult and help
businesses brands to kind of like uh
strategize and have creative directions
for their businesses for their brands
for their communications and then we
work out a branding system expressions
to kind of like uh
move forward the directions and then how
we kind of like
work out all these things is through the
craft of graphic design so basically
that is kind of like the
what we do in the studio yeah
so as a graphic designer
my role you know
you know in a in a short way is that i
convey ideas and information
and uh
i facilitated this role primarily
through designing visual language
basically it's
designing visual forms and visual
elements to kind of express all these
ideas that we conceptualize uh
for the for for the project
so i mean um i've been in this industry
for like a decade pass so doing all this
visual language designing is actually
what i enjoy most doing yeah
so
this is just a kind of like
overview of
the
past works that we have done over a
decade
um you can see that uh we work with
clients big and small uh from the
biggest we have like doing the sg
bicentennial with the prime minister
office to smaller projects like book
designs work with individual artists etc
so for each of this project we try very
hard to kind of have like a designing a
distinct visual language for the project
itself
and
how do we do is that i create abstract
ideas and then express it in visual
forms using
uh shapes symbols colors images letter
forms and typography so all these when
kind of like when you put it together it
kind of constitutes the visual language
of the designer so like idea that we
like an idea that all these visual
languages are trying to express
i feel that good visual language has to
be relevant and meaningful so for this
talk um i just kind of i'd like to share
a few projects that i feel um
um it kind of like uh just to take on
the teams of the talk sessions instead
uh
kind of like
looking back the past of the heritage or
even some sort of like uh like histories
of all these uh brands and
and and projects and then how it kind of
like helped us to
to to to conceptualize and develop a
distinct visual
language for this project
yeah
so one of the first project
i would like to share is the sg by
centennial project um it's two years two
to three years ago
that run nations why um so
this is uh we actually is the brand
agency working with gwd and under jwd
consortium so they kind of invited us to
be the brand agency to work with them on
this campaign and
so
for us is that we work directly with the
prime minister's office and for sg by
centennial if uh just to give you a bit
of a background information
um it's a national commemoration cam
campaign um to celebrate the 700 years
histories of singapore so by
is like 200 year history but for the
campaign itself
they actually kind of planned and wanted
to kind of like uh
you know get uh the public to discover
the 700 year history of singapore that's
way before the rifles time as well which
is very uh which is uh you know have a
wealth of like a history historical kind
of information to discover and learned
about and the this
project interesting in the sense that um
it's
we we have a two kind of like a uh
so-called uh i won't say restrictions
but requirement one is that as you have
known um you know we have the sg50
campaign training the 2015. then
followed by we have the you know the
html that kind of involved so one of the
requirements is that hub for the sg by
centennial campaign um how do we kind of
like evolve uh using kind of have a have
a map that evolved from
what has been done in the sg50 and the
sg mark and second thing is that how do
we tell
the stories or the narrative of the 700
year histories that these sg by
centennial are trying to commemorate
so it was an interesting challenge in
the sense that if you think about the
scope involved and how do we kind of
like um you know
kind of encapsulate everything in the in
the simple visuals in the in the in the
in in a short visual form
so
um you know as we kind of like explore
and play around the whole idea came to
us is that um you know
singapore is known as the little red dot
so we ask the question so basically if
you're looking back so what is literary
dot before it is a little red dot and we
can't play with that whole visual form
the visual form of it is that if you
look at the circles um what is circles
before it is a circle so
if you kind of like play with
mathematics and even a bit of like you
know
drawings and stuff like that you will
know that you know if you take a square
and you add enough sides to it you
become a hexagon and you become an
octagon and eventually it forms enough
sites that it approximate into enough
line segments that it almost looks like
a circle when you look far enough so it
kind of gives us an idea it's almost
like a diamond in the rough kind of a
process so we can we sort of like
you know conceptualize the seven
poly shapes that shows the progressions
of how the circle came about how the
literary dot came about and of course
along the way you know each each of the
progressions is also have a story and
narrative to ila as you know in the
beginning it's just a simple octagon you
know
following the coins
then you know as we develop as a society
economically culturally we have more
events we have more progressions we have
more advances and you know just kind of
like represented by the sites then
eventually it comes to what we known at
the modern modern society of singapore
so from there we just kind of like group
it together and you have the sg by
centennial the visual identity so if you
kind of put it together it's sort of
like a
sequel of the prequel so it still has
that heritage but able to stand it alone
by itself and able to kind of like
express the narrative of what sg
bicentennial is so from there we
you know developed the whole visual
language for the brand
so this is like the local
as uh for the for the campaign
and then we start to develop like the
visual language of it how the logo uh
will be used
in different kind of a visual scenarios
and context and then
this is just some quick example to show
us like uh we developed the stationary
sets for the prime minister office
team for this gene and the amazing team
that we work with the folder and then
how we use the poly shapes elements uh
to indicate the timeline detect the top
back
um i mean you know the twenty dollars
the commemorating of with the sg by
centennial logo in it and then um the
yeah the you know the main thing of it
is the brand identity guide which we
developed so that all the other uh
vendors
uh you know who gonna you know uh work
on events and and all kinds of
activities uh under the sg by centennial
they are able to take these identity
guidelines and then you know develop
their own activities and usage so here
we're trying to kind of like
develop a comprehensive visual language
guidelines on how to use the logo itself
the logo mark and the party shapes
you
the colors for the logo and the
typography
yeah
so sometimes we also like to work with
our long-standing brands because friends
that is
you know been around
have a lot of heritage and history which
we find is a rich source of inspirations
and materials when we work on projects
with with them so leaving brothers is
one of those brands that we
consider a self-fortunate to work with
actually they have been
for those who are not aware of our
living brothers they are famous for
their uh traditional otta nasi lemak and
and you know all the anchovies and
peanuts and you can see uh the the yeah
therefore chaos in all the major malls
and different places so um they actually
came to us to engage us that they
actually kind of forward thinking in the
sense that um they're trying to take the
traditional author
as we all know and love
i think most people love ota um came to
this author and they trying to kind of
push it in a new direction in the sense
that they're trying to kind of like uh
create uh use ota as a base ingredient
to
to to kind of express it in the more
modern cuisine techniques so think of
like ota burger orta fries
orta reuben rose etc so because uh libby
and brothers are known to be like you
know the classic quarter so they're
trying not to dilute the brand but
create a new uh sub brand out of it and
then to kind of like take a new uh sort
of take a new take on the author itself
so they came to us you know we
collaborate we're trying to kind of like
help them to define the creative
directions how we can go about it so um
luckily they decided to name the the new
uh brand called discord ota and it's
sort of like basically um
the problem is just solve it by itself
so for that we basically take what we
love about that and we translate into a
simple modern form so basically alta as
you as you see in the long shape form
you know that it kind of like reminds
you visually immediately like um what
ota is and and from there we kind of
like in a very simple way you know ota
you see those traditional altar they
usually grill they have a lot of you
know author in the in the grill sets so
we're trying to create that sort of like
a visual memory and create a more
graphic visual language motif of it and
from that
we also help them coin the the slogan
fresh stick on the classics and we use
this bright um
very spicy kind of like neon uh
orangey colors against the the bananas
the the green
to kind of like create a very how to say
a
classic but also kind of like a bit of a
contemporary flavor sort of color
palette to the video and then this is
just a quick look of the whole packaging
set
so from there we have like the nasi
lemak with different flavors of ulta and
then this is the
packaging set so we have like
so we're trying to take the this simple
author kind of like a visual identity we
created a motif as a base of the visual
language and then we use it on all the
packagings and you know the paper bags
and stuff like that but we also try not
to just um
mean a plastic all over but we wanted to
kind of like make sure that whenever it
is applied it's applied with a purpose
with uh with some thoughts like
why are we applying it and how does it
relevance to the packaging itself so
here we have like a nice
nine little kind of like a circles is to
indicate the nine different uh contents
that the ingredients that is in the nasi
lemak pack itself and then this also
translates to the burger so this is like
the the ottawa burger which is very good
and then um yeah you have the
the burger shapes on it
and then these are the paper wrap
and then and the paperback itself
so we also uh help them kind of like
design this custom uh
altar packaging so when people order the
author like the scala porta like the
salmon orta which is uh completely new
and all this pack um is a you know
designs for take away and we use the
motif as you can see there's a cut hole
so because ota they kind of like you
know uh they kind of like uh serve it
hot so there's a lot of steam so some of
the things that we're trying to solve is
to have make sure that there's a venting
hole for the packaging and then you know
have the usual that it can release and
you can release peanuts and the sambal
chili
following the same visual language for
the brands in the new packaging so
apparently
the itambilis and the economist peanut
in these colors are very popular with
other aunties uh they've been selling
very well for libya for ottawa and divi
and brother so durian brothers are
actually using the packaging itself
in levy and brothers
yeah so you can actually find it in all
the audio from chaos
there
so this is just some closer look on the
packaging and how we apply
the motif
and this is the economies peanuts and uh
and the anchovies packaging
yeah
so um
i'm
often trying to find opportunities to
actually have
you know um
work with chinese typography in the
project as well and this one actually
came at the right time when everyone
from supermama
came engages like i know would you like
to you know collaborate with them to
design a visual identity for their new
labor manual possibly and you know how
can we say no so for nanyang porcelains
is that um
i actually once i get the brief is you
know we really wanted to incorporate
chinese typography in it for like
southern china you know southeast asia
but then we all have our roots from the
chinese immigrants you know from china's
and stuff like that so porcelain arts
you know it's
in the nangang region is known for all
these
bows basses with intricate arts and
stuff like that so we just got to take
that inspiration and we're trying to
kind of incorporate into the more like
we're trying to kind of like using all
these uh porcelain objects as a form as
the basis and then we're trying to
create a bespoke
uh chinese typefaces for the word
nanyang so as you can see here is the
bow
and the vas for the young so we created
this uh nan yang for serving so
when we kind of
if you wonder why we also kind of like
you know
kind of like
um like
have these uh irregular uh steps to the
nine-year-old crossing so kind of feel
like trying to break that very difficult
logo kind of blind sweet yeah so end up
it actually turns out well and yeah the
result is is what we're quite proud of
yeah and the last one is uh this kind of
very quick i think it's uh
uh sort of like running of time uh
mark green and change and for this
project i would like to just say that
this particular project is actually we
go against the brain in the sense that
we try not to look at the past in order
to design compute
in order to design a visual language for
it so marbling and kane is actually a
new independent uh bottler in singapore
so what bottler does is that they kind
of
sample all the you know whiskey rum and
bourbon around the world and they find
the right kind of like uh you know
right kind of taste to to what they kind
of like
them as a connoisseur and then they kind
of buy it and then they water it under
the label so for migraine you know for
whiskeys and you know
the usual brand is that you know if they
look at that it's like quite kind of
like a almost sealed kind of like uh
graphic series kind of kind of like have
a intricate kind of crest kind of a
branding visual so that you know it
confirms some sort of like a prestige
heritage qualities and stuff but from
upgrade and change we decided to not do
that so what we do is that we basically
take the name which is recognized by our
client markers that mount grain and
chain basically the basic ingredients
for whiskey bourbon and rum and we're
trying to create a modern graphic
interpretations of it so you can see the
the you know the mouth which is the
mouth and the
the grain is the the soft like shapes
and then the crane
the crane which is the sugarcane
sorry
so from there we just create a simple
modern looking uh
identity and from here we developed the
whole visual language for it we wanted
it to kind of like um you know simple
simple yet sophisticated and also kind
of like comfort a certain quality
so this is uh the packaging that we
designed for mountain king year one's uh
first bottle yeah and then a very quick
run-through so we we actually work with
uh our clients uh quite a long time so
on all the print treatments and stuff
like that to to kind of like get it
right and then from there the visual
language that we developed you know put
it in the wrapping papers
name cards and then this is a year one
bottle tool and then the carton boxes
and
you know even the the
selling tape
and then
the visuals the talkback
the digital catalog that we developed
for them for the year one bottles the
foundation years and then um
an entire visual language we're trying
to kind of like capture it and develop
it as a rendering guidelines for our
client as well that you can see here the
color palettes
and then the typography
yeah
so
basically um yeah
thanks for your time um yeah um as
felicia
mentioned earlier we're a
multi-disciplinary practice we work in
different scales and different kind of
across different disciplines from
architecture to interiors to product
design to furniture and the projects i'm
showing today are kind of um they're
kind of ideal projects for us because
they're emblematic of what we hope to do
um and um in a sense that they involve
all different kind of the the different
kind of um skill sets in the office and
we draw on all the different kind of
backgrounds and different kind of
training that the people in the office
have had um they are
both of them for the virgin group of um
companies
um a virgin atlantic um as you know is
was started by richard branson um it's
an airline company based in the uk
um in 2008 we were at that point um
our sort of portfolio up to that point
in time was basically um
sort of private residential architecture
and interiors and we wanted to vary um
our diet of work a little bit so we sent
out portfolios to a few commercial
companies one of them was virgin
atlantic and to our surprise they called
us back
and we thought that initially that they
would ask us to do one of their airport
lounges because that seems like the most
kind of closest in terms of our
experience and relevance um but to our
surprise they called us to
look at
they gave us a test brief basically to
look at the future of flight
so and with the aim of eventually
working on the sort of the the
aircraft cabin
um so that was tremendously exciting and
so we set about sort of i mean i think
the thing about uh virgin the virgin
group of companies they're very kind of
heavy on process and research what they
call the discovery phase and we set
about sort of um
uh trying to research what was the
future of flight what was the future of
luxury and bear in mind this is in 2008
so you know a lot of these things i'm
talking about now are now commonplace
and you know we take for granted but at
the time these things were these ideas
were just coming into being um
so we um
realized that we discovered that the
idea of the old idea of luxuries were
being replaced by new ideas of you know
sort of the old uh ideas of material
luxury were being replaced by
the ideas of kind of
unique experiences
of knowledge
um of intellectual challenge and we kind
of thought about how we might
incorporate it incorporate these into
the virgin
aircraft cabin
um we were also asked to look at so
visual references and we looked at the
work of erwin howard which we like a lot
anthony gaudi um
nocochi
palazzolo and also you know natural
phenomenon like the northern lights then
what we realize with these
images that we've been looking at is
they're all kind of interpretations of
natural phenomenon
and and
they are to do with light most of them
um
so
the the thing the way um the virgin team
works is they have an in-house design
team which are kind of helmed by
uh trained um industrial and product
designers and they would manage us as
the external agencies and working on
these uh these projects
so they encouraged us to play and it was
a really kind of great experience
because you know it was kind of um it
was meeting of like minds in a way and
um they encourage us to play and explore
these kind of different kind of ideas
um of how to bring light into the cabin
um of how to kind of um you know both
artificial light as well as natural
light we went through many iterations
during this test brief so
which are seen on screen and
the the other thing about a virgin is
they are very heavy on
the customer experience so they
encourage us not to design um the
hardware of the cabin interior but also
the the mode the software the passenger
experience how we curate that experience
so we set about kind of discovering how
the light conditions change the sight
line changes during the time of a flight
um how the activity changes um both in
terms of you know convivial activities
and more cocoon-like activities how the
interactions between um crew and
passenger would take place at different
times of the flight
so we did a series of diagrams
and um and then we came up and then also
the um the the main kind of focal point
of the cabin interior for us in terms of
the brief
was to um uh what was their bar so the
thing about virgin atlantic planes is
that they have a bar for the business
class passengers
um
so
this bar is um they already have a bar
sort of you know in the previous
situations of the aircraft so we were
asked to come up with a new iteration
um so
the the one that came before us was the
traditional kind of u-shaped bar where
the bombing would stand or the crew
member would stand behind the u-shape
and then there would be five or six sort
of bar stools where passengers would sit
around um so we wanted to sort of up end
that we wanted to challenge that and we
wanted to kind of come up with a bar
that was more kind of interactive that
was a little bit looser in terms of
backup house front of house relationship
um and then also it would sort of um you
know sort of um allow people to use the
bar in different ways so you could sit
at the bar or you could perch or you
could sort of walk around or stand
around
these are some very early um sort of
concepts so finally you know after going
having kind of passed that test brief we
were given the actual um
commission to to work on the bar um so
this is the plan of the um the final
product so you come in through these
doors and then the bar is arranged at a
diagonal um so that it appears longer or
there is also the possibility of fitting
in more space um you can sort of sit at
the bar store um that's where the crew
member would be behind but you can walk
around him so you can it's not
completely in around you it's not 360
degrees but it's at least 270.
um you can also perch at these kind of
areas here or you can you know stand
around here and then these two little
triangles are sort of what we call
monuments which are which contain
storage for um you know um
spirits as well as magazines
um
so it's very much a piece of mini
architecture because it is a cabin
within the cabin um it's kind of this
wrap-around structure um you know which
forms which kind of peels around to form
the bar surface um
and then you know this is just kind of a
quick video to show you the different
kind of iterations that we went through
um and it was a very long process it
took about three or four years so um it
starts with um sort of these computer
models of
how you know we would sort of
accommodate the um
the
the the storage as well as light within
these kind of the peels of of this
skin
um
and where there's appeal that the
texture might change or or there will
there might be light inserted in in
where there's a way where there's a
break in the surface as well
um
and then you know we also sort of went
from um you know of these computer
models to physical models so
um you know it started out as kind of
half scale um card models in our office
and then i went to the kind of the
aircraft hangar um where we would
install kind of full-scale models um
images will come up in a sec
of the models
so these are the early polystyrene
models
and then we went on to sort of put in
sort of more realistic materials
um and the actual materials finally
and the actually the final product
um
um so some final images of the of the
bar itself so these are the three kind
of bastards on the on the left hand side
um and then you see the peel of the um
the bar structure kind of going overhead
and where there's a break there's the
light
with this light or there's kind of
accommodation for you know glasses etc
and because it is a plane every single
millimeter count is so you know where
there is um accommodation given over to
glasses for instance and you you take
away some i mean you know every there
isn't a spare kind of um you know square
centimeter or cubic centimeter in in
this structure
um uh glasses uh storage
um and that's the back of the bar where
the um the crew member would stand
so as you can see it's it's kind of
quite nicely finished so there is no
messiness or anything like that so you
know it is a presentable part of the
experience as well
these are the purchase but i mentioned
earlier so you can purchase um you know
and and be part of that sort of
convivial environment
um a couple of years later we had the
opportunity of working with the virgin
group again and this time as you know um
richard branson you know he's one of the
billionaires in this world who is in
that space race
and um he set up a company called virgin
galactic
with the idea of you know doing
commercial flights into space
and currently they're based out of
spaceport america which is um in the new
mexico desert
it's a building designed by by norman
foster
um it's a circular building
but with a little bit of an earthworks
kind of tail um so you enter through
here through this kind of
corten clad tunnel and then you actually
go down in level as well
and then you you come up and
until you kind of finally enter this
kind of circular building
and the building is split into three
parts
so the the first part would be the um
the kind of admin and offices the middle
part the hanger for the spacecraft and
then the final part will be the public
area of the um
the building which is the
it comprises the lounge the offices as
well as the training center and that's a
fully glazed facade which faces the
runway which is this kind of um
straight
piece of tarmac here
so our brief was to
look at the lounge
as well as the offices we were asked to
do the offices later
um
the um so that's that's the pie that is
the segment of the the circular circular
building um you enter through this kind
of
walkway which we call the astro walk um
so this is where you come into this
space from from the you know from from
the rest of the building um and it's
also where the um the astronauts i mean
the people who sort of pay to go on
these flights are called astronauts so
the web this is where the astronauts
would sort of um go
um
um through to to before they embark onto
the uh spacecraft beyond here
so um and then the lounge is to one side
of this astral walk
um and it is a place where it has
different functions it is a place where
um the astronauts will come and sort of
you know hang out and and meet with the
interact with the the pilots or the crew
it's also where friends and family would
um you know sort of rest when the flight
is actually taking place it's where the
press would also gather
and during non-flight days because the
flight doesn't take place every day um
on flight days the uh the people who
work in that building they use it as
their cantinas and the extended living
basically so there is a food kind of um
facility here so there's a
there is a pantry or surgery which is
connected to the main kitchen and the
rest is kind of like a
open plan space
um there is a um
gallery kind of office built uh office
floor above
but you know the most of it is double
height on on this side of the the pie
is a sort of a multi-purpose space um
which we
um
it's a it's a phase two kind of scenario
but um it hasn't really sort of taken
place yet
um so
as usual with the virgin group i think
they're very kind of um
into
getting the concept right that they're
very into kind of um you know the uh
designing the passenger experience and
we were working with a creative not not
with a in-house design team but with a
creative director who was in charge of
the overall
um
uh ideas of uh so the overall kind of
visuals of the um things like the well
the lounge obviously and then also the
uniforms the spacecraft so he has an
overview of
the um the entire passenger journey so
excuse me um so what was important was
you know we had to identify very early
on
where our sort of lounge sat in that
journey so um you know it's obviously
the sort of the the flexion point or the
fulcrum
you know as one transitions from earth
to to to space
um
and then you know and then also we were
taking cues from the actual building
because you know norman foster's
building also had that sense of
transition as you entered the sort of
the building from this kind of court and
clad tunnel into the actual building and
then you emerge into this kind of very
light fully glazed space um finally so
you know we wanted our um our space to
also have that sense of transition of
the sense of
[Music]
progression
in terms of opacities in terms of
texture in terms of the light
environment
these are some of the expansion of these
images of these ideas of the materials
and textures and colors for um you know
i think i think what was important was
for us not to replicate this kind of
sense of being in space because you know
there's no point
trying to replicate on earth when you're
about to sort of go into space itself so
we wanted to celebrate the idea that you
are actually on mother earth um and you
know but mother being on mother earth
has kind of different kind of you know
there's a there's a temperature there's
a range of temperature of being very
very kind of you know dense and very
warm to do something much more ethereal
much lighter but you know it's still you
know pretty it's still very much off the
earth
and also because you know it had to the
space had to kind of um
uh
accommodate different people at
different points of time and also you
know different days and different types
of people um we also wanted to
um
to kind of map out how this uh
servery and the served and serving
spaces would work in that in that area
in open plan space so we were mapping
out you know how these would affect
different kind of um
passenger or you know circulation flows
and
where there is a
um you know sort of a focal point
concept for the self-serving space or
it's a sort of more like a field where
it's a little bit more scattered um some
early kind of um
studies into how seating might work
whether it's a sort of whether it's
convivial seating whether it's more
individual seating
or whether it has a focal point um in
the middle here
um we also did light studies
and because this the sun in that part of
new mexico is very very strong
especially very early in the morning
so we just wanted to um you know sort of
make sure
there were no surprises in terms of you
know glare and stuff like that
and also like studies in terms of um
the evening
um and then also like we
you know uh
as i said before you know we were trying
to celebrate the fact that we are on
mother earth and so we were actually we
went on these kind of hikes in a nearby
kind of areas
to look at the geology of of the space
around and we wanted to kind of uh let
uh absorb those influences and also
translate it into the furniture that we
were designing so for instance in this
case the the upholstery details
um and having some of these kind of
rough concepts we mapped it out in the
spaces itself so this is the um
the double height space i was talking
about
um the the gallery sort of office spaces
above um and that's the area where you
come into um that's the astral wall that
you come into
um so we mapped it out with uh we we
plotted it out with
usb boards and in plastic office
furniture
just to kind of test site lines
to test kind of um groupings um
and whether the size of the um
the uh the group the grouping you know
whether that's an optimum size for you
know a table setting
or whether it's more kind of individual
seating by the window
we also brought materials to site to
test how you know like the very strong
sunlight would
react with it in terms of translucency
and then also in terms of filtering the
very strong sunlight
so that's a planner for the space that
we came up with finally um so you enter
the um
the the the space through this astral
walk um on the right hand side of the
screen and then there is this raised
area which connects to the servery and
the kitchen
and then
around this kind of race platform are
two very large surface which are you
know the convivial parts of the
seating area
and they kind of surround this kind of
barista what we call the barista island
which is like the focal point
which is where you pick up your drinks
and juices and stuff like that and this
is also where you could sort of you know
sort of
uh
hang out and meet people and then along
the window are sort of more kind of um
slightly more secluded seating because
it is away from the sort of the main
center of attract uh center of activity
um but they they kind of um accommodate
different
groups of different sizes so you have a
slightly larger
area here which we call the messer and
then a slightly smaller one and then
these are more individual kind of window
seats
um
a section through
showing the double height space then you
have the first floor kind of
office area and then you know that that
sort of overlooks
from the gallery this double height
space onto the the lounge below um we
wanted to because the the back wall is
the the only solid wall um it had to
accommodate a lot of services a lot of
sound insulation acoustic insulation
um a lot of storage requirements so in
order to kind of um
organize all of that we we created this
kind of wooden screen which transitions
from being very dense and very dark from
from ground and going up to being much
lighter and much more um much less
opaque
and then also it transitions to this
kind of mesh um ceiling um
structures which also help to filter the
sun
section through the um
the gala the galleried kind of um
lounge as well as the office above
so these are some kind of site um
photos um you see the barista island in
the foreground and then you have this
two large surface on here and here
look a view down the um the astral walk
and you have these kind of tilted
mirrors above i'll explain why a little
while
um
a barista island
in the middle of the space
um and then the the the timber slats
also become the bow straight at the top
um and this is um we we lined the
uh astroworld with these kind of
interactive or touch sensitive led
screens um so the video content can be
changed and then you know during a
flight for example when the astronauts
walk down towards their flight it could
leave for prince in the sun for instance
blah blah blah but during the flight
itself it could also be um they could
also project you know the information on
the flight you know in in real time so
that friends and family can see it on
that sort of reflective mirror
some views of the
final space
and finally a video showing how it is
being used
by the virgin galactic family
so these are some views of the office
above that we designed as well
[Music]
thank you
thank you voon we will now be moving on
to the q a segment of today's session so
if i could invite all speakers to join
us back on screen please and to our
audience to continue posting your
questions for speakers through the q a
function so kelly handing the time back
over to you
thanks felicia uh awesome presentation
boon that was really cool thank you
uh okay we have again once again many
questions so i'm going to start with
each one because your questions came in
first earlier on uh the first question
is hi each and thanks for sharing with
us what inspired your very unique
approaches to design
okay thanks for the question
so i
think i once
um
in two ways one is um you know i always
approach the project looking at what is
the most essential
um
that
makes the project come into being for
example
with the summer miller project i
actually researched um
like more than 50 chairs and basically
finally i found that the eems was the
one of the most iconic pieces of
furniture they they
do carry
um from hamamilla
and um then i started look looking at
how uh the motor plywood got introduced
into the whole furniture design
language and they were kind of inspired
by
leg spleens that were used to support
you know broken fractured legs during
second world war
and they imported that technique uh into
furniture so
so that became the kind of inspiration
for example for for this project
likewise i look for
maybe uh like what would be the most
essential or the kind of deep structure
within
a situation uh when i approach any any
project and most of the time this gives
me
some some kind of inspiration second
thing is
it's more selfish it's more like uh i
wanted to continue practicing and doing
research at the same time so there
should be a continuity in my projects
um from project to project so i ask
what are the you know questions that i
would like answered in the next project
when it comes along
so um i would then propose uh solutions
that would enrich or kind of further
the ongoing research that my studio has
so i think
yeah i think most of the time it's
balance between the two because most of
my research
come from
paid projects
and and that's how i think we can
accumulate
knowledge as we go along in practice
thank you ichun
uh next question i will shoot to
jonathan uh jonathan how do you manage
the sensibility sensitivities when
working on projects that hold a lot of
cultural weight heritage and meaning
and how do you balance that with
creative ideas
okay uh thanks for the questions um i
think
it just it's something that um you know
uh
uh for every project that we actually
kind of like uh make sure that we do is
that um
whatever creative ideas or even our
approach to designs and whatever we're
trying to do trying to push the envelope
and stuff it should always in the
service of our clients
uh our project our the step in service
to the subject to to our clients to to
to what we're trying to stop so
in the sense is that um whatever we're
trying to push and and what we're trying
to to kind of do like out of the box or
like trying to you know be creative and
you know explore in the ways that has
been done but
if it doesn't work for
that project in the sense that it
doesn't fulfill what we're trying to
achieve for it then i don't think it
works out so it's always that kind of
like benchmark or at least the skills
it's kind of like help us to kind of
like bring in in terms of how we
approach the project without going
overboard
yeah and most of the time is our client
is the best uh tesla right you know when
we're trying some you know crazy kind of
like creative directions and our clients
like
i'm not too sure then we know that we
are not
uh
we are not
striking in the right ways or we are
just kind of speaking our own way
without actually trying to solve the
problem in the right way yeah
i hope that cannot answer your question
okay thanks jonathan okay boone uh
here's one for you
uh the question goes hi boone where do
you start when designing such futuristic
projects like the spaceport or things
that haven't been done before
where do you get your reference points
um
we start at the beginning
i think
for example like the spaceport
project we were helped by the
the virgin galactic team in the sense
that they
um allowed us time to really do a lot of
kind of research
and to do a lot of kind of work up front
in terms of concept work and i think
that was very important so there was a
we spent many many months kind of
discussing with the creative director
about the concept
excuse me of the um
around the space before we actually put
any sort of designs or put you know so
make any lines on paper so i think you
know sort of um trying to understand
um
the nature of space travel we were you
know asked to watch you know various
kind of films and documentaries about
space travel um
doing that sort of making those hikes in
in a new mexico desert
um
um understanding you know sort of
going to site to understand you know how
their crew might sort of use that space
you know et cetera et cetera all these
different strands would kind of
come into um i mean it's i don't think
it's any different from designing any
other project really um
it's just like the um
program is a little bit different from
you know what we normally do
you think i hope that answers the
question
ah each and i have a question for you
so uh because you are um you know you're
very experimental and do quite a lot of
this computational parametric
architecture does form follow function
apply in this sort of exploration
um
not really i mean i think
from
in my mind uh
follows a certain purpose
right
and function purpose has a more
encompassing
definition
so it's not so so much the utilitarian
function that we are after but
purpose
suggests
a larger narrative that can be
used to
look into context
and sometimes they go beyond
the immediate context in this case
the context that i
may want to look at could be
the fourth industrial revolution
revolution for example
but i i i do
then think that um
they are forming in a way
when i think of it from a purpose point
of view
um
allows uh me to better argue
for for the existence of
you know either a method or
the the actual outcome itself
at the end of the day i think most of
the time the form is
where the physical form the
object is a result of the process
and i i most of the time would argue for
the existence of the process to take
place before
you know the final
image that appears after that
yeah i i don't know if they answer your
question okay thanks maybe i i post the
same question to boon since you know
it's a it's a very architectural
question to always ask whether we should
you know subscribe to form follows
function so voon how um
how much of your work you know subscribe
to this idea of form follows function or
do you think that um the existence of a
more conceptual narrative is more
important as a driver for your design
um
i guess i'm quite old school
so
form file is functioning for me i mean i
know that you know lots of different
approaches but for us i think um foreign
and then also i think you know um
through working with the virgin group i
think what is kind of quite important is
also
the the user experience
so you know
designing the experience of the the end
user is is also quite um
that's what you know we've learned from
you know working with companies like
that
um
so it's the function in a way
um is kind of a little bit more
articulated in a sense because you know
um it is not so
you know because it's a little bit more
complex
um
so i think you know that
that always is the sort of the
determinant of the the form for us
okay thanks uh jonathan so i'm gonna
tweak this same question a little bit to
you so for graphic designers um usually
we prescribe to form following content
um so i think for branding usually we
can have a story and all that to follow
but how about when it comes to things
like designing let's just say a brochure
a book um how do you how do you you know
prescribe that kind of a solution or you
don't
um
i would say
the so far the kind of uh how we kind of
like have our creative process is always
um
for every project even like designing
just a book or something we always want
to make sure that there's a certain idea
that we want to kind of have like
whether the idea is like how we wanted
um you know the book um to be flipped
and then there's a this particular
tactile experience that kind of like
create a narrative to understand a bit
more of the content etc so um the form
is always i guess in the service of idea
yeah we always have to want to um we
always insist and emphasize internally
that we always should have some form of
ideas or at least
actually like you can say a purpose like
why are we doing this and then
the form which is a craft the graphic
design the visual language is all to
express this idea
yeah so i'm not sure like
is it like form for row functions but
more like i will say from follow the
ideas of what we are trying to do yeah
okay thank you uh okay here's a question
for all three of you uh from
uh this person called
hello all thank you so much uh to the
speakers i guess this is a more generic
question to everyone in today's world
where the dissemination of information
and data for public use is of increasing
importance to national health and
security
how can design teams
create works that reach across
generations to communicate increasingly
more complex issues and data sets
very hard to
answer uh shall we start with uh maybe
once since you're the more experienced
of the tree
oh my god
i'm still trying to process that
question
i think i think in short this
it's about how designer can improve um
you know maybe like systems of health
and security
but i think you know things like
that all these kind of um
i think a lot of these requirements are
kind of embedded or institutionalized
already because you know like for
example in the uk there's we're very
stringent health and safety kind of um
regulations to conform to which is part
of the sort of um you know this the
approval process
um so
so that is already a kind of you know
it's already embedded in the
requirements of the project and of
course there are other requirements like
you know sustainability etc etc which
again you know i'm becoming more and
more kind of embedded into the
requirements of the project
so um i mean
obviously you can go to the beyond a
sort of basic minimum to to achieve you
know sort of even higher targets of
you know health and sustainability etc
etc but um
you know i would say from from our point
of view it's already you know it's
already sort of part of what we have to
do
okay uh each one and jonathan what's
your take on this
yeah i think
um
i think following what wouldn't say i i
feel like for example things like
sustainability
the data is not very well
understood by a lot of people
so one thing is i think for designers
maybe
it is about um making one uh people
general public aware of sustainability
targets for example like we don't know
like how much energy has been used now
in zoom like we are having this zoom
here but that's not that we can't read
this right so a lot of this date
not our
uh that there's no way of understanding
this and
i feel like we are at the stage where we
can actually
make this awareness very heightened it
becomes second nature for us to know
some of this data that is important for
us
so and then this data can
be used for many different things for
example
um people can
uh it's not it's data you know once they
become streamlined and and be classified
into different categories then you know
we can use this information for research
and to better certain systems and so on
and so forth
and that that is then
bringing this data into context
otherwise it would just be noise like
for example we are still not clear how
we count carbon emission for example
there's so much data out there yeah and
a lot of it but there's a textbook
increasing though yeah exactly yeah so
so i think
streamlining it
and then making it digestible and
making it uh part of the awareness
this is
the immediate uh step forward
i don't know
jonathan do you want to add on to this
um if i understand the question
correctly like how
design
team
create work across generations
communicate increasingly more complex
issues and data i think it's like uh if
uh
if i can just think of it as like how uh
how can we create kind of timeless
designs that communicate um you know
across generations
on increasingly complex issues and data
set i think um
the way i see is that also the way uh i
myself a designer trying to kind of like
practice is uh principles and honesty so
as long as um i feel like if i approach
every project with a certain principles
and honesties and and and without being
kind of like influenced by a lot of more
kind of like uh
temporary kind of
um kind of influences and stuff like
that i think at least the work can stood
the test of time and also in terms of
how
i approach a project with honesty on how
i understand interpret and and kind of
like solve it um i think i've done my
part and also in hope that it's timeless
enough that it actually can reach beyond
the the time frame of the project yeah
it's just how we look at look back at
all these classic work like you know
from you know architecture
furniture graphic design visual designs
art you know all these work that you
know i think all the all the designers
and artists itself i think a project
with a certain honesty whether to
themselves or to the subject they are
working on and that's how it transcends
the so-called the generations so to
speak like yeah
okay so uh since you're here jonathan uh
here's a question for you hi jonathan
were you inspired by
me logo mi mi logo redesign
for the seventh evolution of circus
concept
okay uh
okay um the energy by centennial uh
campaign actually runs in 2019 so we did
it end of 2018
so we actually did it way before we
introduced a new logo so few so yeah we
are we
definitely we did it before this new
logo introductions and stuff like that
yeah
okay thanks if that answer the question
okay uh ichan there's another question
for you uh it goes hi jean thank you for
showcasing that amazing paneling idea
how does the maintenance work
is it costly do you dismantle the
structure should one of the pieces fall
apart or becomes 40
yeah so the foreign question
maintenance is always the top question
but um
um that's so the systems are i mean we
can assemble it therefore we can take it
apart so everything is designed as keto
parts and
if it's uh
for example the
the music theater
um the hexagonal uh
vault
you can take pieces down easily
without compromising the structural
integrity of the overall flaws because
the the forces continue down
from other panels
so
if there's anyone that is for example
the speaker that is hidden within
this panel is broken it can be easily
rectified
so i think
in terms of repair is not that much
problem
although right now we are trying to
train the team
to do this installation and repair so
it's not just always coming back to us
uh maintenance
you know like people who own these fancy
cars they spend a lot on maintenance
yeah so i think this question
idea should be put back to the client
right i mean
yeah
i mean if you buy a fancy car you spend
a lot on on waxing it changing the parts
although of course i tried to
design some of these issues out
initially but i think that should be uh
you know give and take
if if
if clients are asking for something that
is more unusual therefore then we have
to think of how to
maybe clean it
so for example uh previously i
designed wow rocket for william lowe as
a restaurant and it's made of like
i know like
thousands of daytons
so um he actually did up a roster
to associate his staff would
um you know
regularly uh dust the
letters
so i think it's a collaboration between
us and the client
to bring this
bring these things to life yeah
absolutely fully agree with you on that
yeah
uh okay here's a question
dear von
thank you for sharing with us
any difference to how you approach
projects for different countries
no
um i think
you know i don't have geographical um i
don't have different geographical
approaches um i think it's just
dependent on the client and the brief i
mean we would
we would slightly tweak our approach
i mean obviously our central approach is
you know because it is always us who's
doing the design um it's it's more or
less the same but you know obviously you
know within that there is a sort of
bandwidth of different um you know ways
you can sort of tweak your approach to
suit the brief to suit the client to see
the situation but um i don't think
that's geographically
driven
okay
um how about uh clients uh clients
expectation different across different
geographies
in the uk you know it's very you know um
historical buildings are treated with
much more um you know instead of you
know kid gloves
um whereas in singapore it's you know
the the sort of
tear down and rebuild kind of scenario
is much more prevalent
so it's a slightly different approach to
history um or historical buildings um
but i um as i discussed with you earlier
uh the other time um i think the the
differences kind of across the sort of
geographical regions are sort of getting
smaller and smaller um you know people
are much more kind of have a slightly
more international mindset
uh jonathan here's another question for
you
goes hello mr yuan
i know you've worked with many brands
that have traditional roots
as a designer who works with chinese
typography and traditional aesthetics
which you can have a lot of detail
how do you reconcile that with the
modern image a lot of brands portray now
do you ever feel it detracts from the
traditional aesthetics
sincerely a big fan
yeah thanks for the questions um i think
um
one of the things that we always do if
when it comes to like if let's say we
are working with
a a long-standing brand and then um a
certain projects that require us to kind
of like um express a certain part of it
in a more kind of like a modern
modern context i guess the word is the
context so we're trying to kind of like
put context into what we are trying to
do and then how to
and how to reconcile it based on context
so for example sometimes like uh
like for example the author project um
for for us is that you know ota is it's
kind of like it is a traditional food
and then um you know when we look around
like all kinds of like branding and
graphic design that's been done for ota
and then we look at it and then we see
like dusty feels like it's something
that if we kind of put it up now that it
will be relevant or at least it kind of
like
able to kind of like speak to a younger
generation from now to 5-10 years on so
how do we kind of like um you know
approach it in such that we don't
lose the heritage but then we are still
able to kind of like move it forward so
these are the kind of context that we
kind of put it in and then trying to
solve it yeah in the sense that yeah
if that makes sense to the questions
i hope yeah the person who asked is
happy with that that's another question
for you
uh so i think this person was referring
to your ota packaging packaging
it says the packaging looks compelling
do you consider materials sources waste
and reduction of material use in your
design process
okay um
i would honestly answer these questions
is that no because the entire packaging
manufacturing uh kind of like process
was handled by the client so our client
actually has their own manufacturing
partners and stuff like that kind of
like handles all the in terms of the
type of paper use and how you can
manufacture this and stuff so we just
kind of came into what we then in terms
of the designs but i can understand the
question in terms of like doing
packaging designs
you know we have to kind of consider the
ways and and
and you know the kind of people that we
use like is it the type type you know
acid fees or like you know
certifications and stuff like that so um
ultimately it really depends per project
like some most of the time the kind of
packaging work that we work on
um
usually we work closely with clients and
there is a certain restrictions in terms
of budgets and stuff like that so we try
our best to be you know as as as green
or like you know as
it sounds good as possible but
ultimately it still depends on a lot of
factors to kind of like make it
make it work yeah if that's kind of
answer the question
yeah thank you okay here's a question
for all three uh panelists uh the
question goes how do the panelists
address diversity
in one work and second
in teams
so again maybe we start reboot
um
how do i address diversity i i guess you
mean in terms of
ethnic background
you know gender et cetera et cetera um
i i guess we just kind of um in in our
team you know we we try to be as i mean
i don't know it's almost like uh when we
hire people it's almost kind of like uh
you know we don't release
okay let's let's just say that um but i
i think there are some companies that
uh hire they have a certain quota of say
you know some someone from an ethnic
minority they have to hire blah blah
blah you
um
we don't really take that approach i
mean i think we just kind of we almost
kind of have a blindfold kind of over
our eyes when we hire someone because we
just look at the portfolio and that
person is suitable we hire that person i
think you know um you know whether i
mean i i'm the kind of ethnic minority
in my team
so
i think that box
um so um
so yeah so we don't really sort of have
a policy in that sense um
in terms of our work i'm not sure how we
address diversity because you know
it's dependent on the project that we
get i'm sorry i don't know how to answer
that question
yeah okay i'll spare jonathan this
question because you work only with your
wife
correct correct since you have a big
team
yeah
yeah i actually agree we would i i don't
consider
um
each gender you know um that kind of
thing so i don't even look at grades so
i just look at the work yeah
and
diversity in work
comes with
um
i i think i'm just focused on every
project that i get so
i hope for diversity that means like you
know i want to do a
forty story tower next time
so
but you know some things you can only
wish
okay so uh i think we're coming to the
the final question because uh it's
already six four to five uh so last
question uh from grace time for all of
you
what would you recommend a beginner
designer to do to gain traction in
design
boon
first think the clue's in the name
because we all have design practices so
i think it involves practice just
you know just got to keep doing it
you know until you get better and and
get kind of you know you gain experience
okay uh jonathan
um
at least for graphic design i think most
important thing is stay true to yourself
and then just work hard
harder than anyone and then like
wednesday you know you just have to keep
work keep doing so that you you know you
keep kind of like um mature in a sense
the more you do the more you have
experience the more you mature and then
it kind of like majority kind of on your
sensitivity haunts the way you think
hans like how you kind of like have more
experience in certain like you know
handlings all kinds of like uh situation
and and also kind of like makes you
generate a better designers so i think
that is the only way is to kind of like
get better as a
beginner as a beginner you know yeah so
but among all these don't just kind of
like work hard without a plan or without
uh you know thinking like so which is
why um as a designer i think stay true
to yourself it's also one of the most
important thing you have to have your
own voice rather than being just a
you know
mindless armies that just chunk out work
you have to find your own voice and how
and kind of do a lot more to find
your own ways in solving things that is
i feel that is what makes a designer
interesting yeah
okay
that's really
sick
you want to
share your
yeah
actually
i think
when you just started out
it's actually the best time to reject
projects that you do not feel like you
have a say
because actually when i have a big team
now sometimes it's really difficult to
reject certain projects
so on the contrary when you are small
you're nimble
you you should learn to reject those
projects that where you feel you cannot
contribute
you cannot intervene
meaningfully because
once you start to compromise that
determines the next project that you're
going to get the profile starts to
change and it's very hard to break out
that more
so i would
encourage people to
reject when they still can
okay thank you thank you all um
before i head over to felicia uh we have
a very kind and generous compliment from
one of the
audience today so i'm just gonna share
it quickly
she or he said this whole session just
backs the question
when are the three of you going to work
on a project together seems like a match
made in heaven
so
thank you guys okay so with that i'm
going to hand over back to felicia to
close the session thank you guys so much
for this very inspiring session
thank you thank you thank you
alicia back to you
thank you kelly cheung jonathan and voon
for taking the time to join us today and
for sharing your insights with us it has
been an absolute pleasure to hear from
all of you so more in-depth interviews
with our speakers can also be found on
studio sml's website along with podcasts
on studio sml spotify channel so if
you're keen do scan the relevant qr
codes that you see on your screen the
links are also currently being provided
to you in our zoom chat and if you'd
like to find out more about the other
programs at the national design center
do scan the qr code that you see on the
right this is where i will now leave you
so thank you once again for joining us
today and we definitely hope to see you
at our future events take care and
goodbye